In this segment, we
go through an example
to get some practice with
Poisson process calculations.
The example is as follows.
You go fishing and fish
are caught according
to a Poisson process with
an arrival rate-- that
is the rate at which fish are
caught-- of 0.6 fish per hour.
You will fish for two
hours no matter what.
And if during
those two hours you
have caught at least
one fish, then you stop.
As in this scenario, in which
you have caught three fish
during the first two
hours, and then you stop.
Otherwise, you will continue
until you catch one fish.
And at that time, you will stop.
We will answer a few questions
and we will write down
the answers to these questions
in terms of the notation
that we have introduced.
And here, for reference,
we have all of the formulas
that we have developed so far.
The first question is,
what is the probability
that you get to fish
for more than two hours?
Well, you get to fish for more
than two hours if and only
if you didn't catch any fish
during the first two hours.
So this is the
probability of catching
zero fish in the
first two hours.
And we can use this formula.
Substitute k equal
to 0, tau equal to 2,
lambda equal to 0.6.
Plug in the numbers and
obtain a numerical answer.
We will not bother [with]
the numerical answers,
we will just be writing
down the expressions that
give us the answers.
Now, in this question we could
have a different approach.
You will fish for
more than two hours
if and only if there are no
arrivals during the first two
hours, which means
that the first arrival
in the Poisson process of
fishing happens after time 2.
So we're talking about the event
that the first arrival, T1,
is bigger than 2.
And we're looking
into the probability
of this event, which is
the integral of the density
of the first arrival time.
And the integral is
taken over the range
of values of interest--
larger than 2.
That is, from 2 to infinity.
We know that this
density is exponential,
so we can write down this
integral and evaluate it.
So notice the difference
between these two approaches.
Here we think in terms of
the random variables that
correspond to the
number of arrivals
during a certain time interval.
Here we're reasoning in
terms of inter-arrival times.
And more generally, for
Poisson process problems,
an event of interest
sometimes can
be expressed in terms
of number of arrivals.
Or sometimes it can
be expressed in terms
of arrival and
inter-arrival times.
Or sometimes both
approaches are possible.
But usually one of
the two approaches
will be simpler than the other.
For example, here we
already have a formula,
whereas here we would need
to evaluate an integral.
Here is now our next question,
which is a little bit more
complicated.
What is the probability
that you get
to fish for more than
two hours, and also you
get to fish for less
than five hours?
This is the scenario,
again, that you
fish for more than two hours,
which means that no fish were
caught during the
first two hours.
And then you continue fishing.
And by time 5 you have
already caught your fish
and you have left.
Now, it is convenient of
thinking about the Poisson
process as follows.
Think about the Poisson
process of catching fish
at the rate of 0.6 per
hour as going on forever.
So there's a fisherman
who fishes forever,
except that this fisherman
at either this time,
under this scenario, or at
that time, under this scenario,
raises a flag and
says, OK, this is
the time I should be stopping.
So even though the fisherman
will stop fishing at this time,
we can imagine the Poisson
process keeps going on.
With this way of
thinking, the fact
that you stopped fishing
before time 5 is the event
and that the number
of fish caught,
or the number of Poisson
arrivals during the interval
from 2 to 5 is at least equal
to 1, larger than or equal to 1.
So the event of interest
consists of the intersection
of two events, zero fish caught
during the first two hours--
which has this probability--
and at least one
arrival in the Poisson process
between times 2 and 5--
this is a time
interval of length 3.
And having at least
one arrival is
1 minus the probability
of 0 arrivals
in a time interval of length 3.
Notice that I'm multiplying
those two probabilities here.
Why am I doing this?
In a Poisson process,
whatever happens
in disjoint time intervals
are independent events.
So an event having to
do with this interval--
the event that no
fish were caught--
and the event that has to do
with this interval-- at least
one fish caught, at least
one arrival during this time
interval-- these two
events are independent.
And this is why we can
multiply their probabilities.
Now, let us think of the
alternative approach,
a different way of
describing this event using
arrival and inter-arrival times.
What is this event?
This is the event that
no arrival happened
until this time, but an
arrival happened before time 5.
So this is the event
that the first arrival
happens after time
2, but before time 5.
And we're looking
at the probability
of this event, which we
can find by integrating
the PDF of the first
arrival time from 2 until 5.
The next question is,
what is the probability
that we catch at least two fish?
Under this scenario, we
catch one fish and we stop.
Therefore, this scenario
must have materialized.
The event of catching
at least two fish
is the scenario that
from time from 0 until 2,
we caught at least two fish.
So we're talking
about the probability
of catching at least
two fish, which
is the probability of
catching k fish during a time
interval of length 2, where
k can be anything from 2
to infinity.
So this is the probability
that the number
of fish caught during
these two time units
is at least equal to 2.
And an alternative way of
writing this expression
so that we do not have to
evaluate an infinite sum,
it is 1 minus the probability
of catching 0 fish,
and minus the probability
of catching 1 fish.
If we were to write
this in terms of arrival
and inter-arrival times, we
will catch at least two fish
if and only if by the time we
stop-- which will be time 2--
we've had 2 arrivals, which
means that the second arrival
time happened before time 2.
So we're looking
into the probability
that the second arrival time
happened before time 2, which
is the integral from
0 to 2 of the density
of the second arrival time.
We have a formula
for this density
given by the Erlang PDF.
So we could take this
expression, plug it in here,
evaluate the integral,
and obtain the same answer
as we would have obtained here.
Clearly, in this case as
well, this first approach
would be a simpler one because
these probabilities are already
available to us.
The next question
is the following.
Suppose that you already
fished for three hours.
This is something
that can only happen
under the second scenario.
So no fish have being
caught until time 2.
You continue.
No fish were caught
until time 3.
And given that this
event has occurred,
what is the expected value
of the future fishing time?
The expected value until a fish
gets caught for the first time?
Well, the Poisson process
starts fresh at time 3,
no matter what
happened in the past,
no matter what information
we're given in the past.
Now you're sitting at time 3
and looking into the future.
You have a fresh
starting Poisson process,
as if this was the initial time.
Starting from this time, the
time until the first arrival
is going to have an exponential
distribution with parameter
lambda, and the expected
value of this distribution
is equal to 1 over lambda.
Finally, let's look at a
different type of question.
What is the expected
value of the total time
that you get to fish?
Let us introduce
here some notation.
Let us call the total
fishing time capital F.
And the total fishing time
consists of two pieces.
There's a time until
time 2 that you
will be fishing no matter what.
And then there's going to
be the remaining fishing
time after time 2.
So now let's look
at the expectation
of the remaining fishing
time after time 2.
Here there are two scenarios.
In the first scenario, you stop.
In the second
scenario, you continue.
And we will take into
account these two scenarios
by using the total
expectation theorem.
The first scenario happens
with some probability.
This is the probability that
you stop fishing at time 2.
And in that case, your
remaining fishing time
is going to be equal
to 0 because you do not
continue under that scenario.
But there's the other
scenario that you
get to fish for more
than 2 time units.
And then we multiply
this term with
the conditional expectation
of the remaining fishing time,
given that you got to fish
for more than 2 times units.
So what is this term?
The probability that you get
to fish for more than 2 time
units, this is the
probability that no fish
were caught during
the first time units.
This is the probability
of the second scenario.
And then we have this
conditional expectation.
Given that you
didn't catch anything
and, therefore, you will
be continuing fishing,
what is the expected amount
of time-- F minus 2--
that you will be fishing?
Now the Poisson process
starts fresh at time 2.
So looking into
the future, we're
faced with a Poisson
process and we're
asking for the expected time
until the first arrival.
And this time has an expected
value equal to 1 over lambda.
Our last question is
of a similar type.
What is the expected number
of fish you're going to catch?
Once more, we will break
this into two pieces.
Number of fish caught
during the first two hours,
and number of fish caught
during the remaining hours.
During the first two
hours, the expected number
of fish that you catch
is given by this formula.
It is equal to lambda tau--
and in our case lambda is 0.6
and tau is equal to 2-- plus
the expected number of fish
that are caught afterwards.
What is this expected value?
Again, we think in terms of
the total expectation theorem.
There's one scenario that
has a certain probability,
and under that scenario
you do not catch any fish.
So that doesn't give
us any contribution.
Then there is this
scenario, the second one,
that has this
probability of occurring.
The probability of
catching no fish here,
so that the second
scenario materializes.
And if that second
scenario materializes,
how many fish are you going
to catch after time 2?
It's going to be one
fish with certainty.
And this is the final
answer to this question.
Notice that in answering
both of these questions
we used the divide and
conquer strategy twice.
We first divided the time
horizon into two pieces
and dealt separately with
each one of the pieces.
And then in order to deal
with this second piece--
the time after time
2-- we used divide
and conquer into the
two different scenarios
and using the total
expectation theorem.